okay today for our daily cancellation
something long overdue we're gonna be
canceling mommy bloggers all of them
they needed to be cancelled years ago I
think it's probably too late for
intervention at this point but someone
has to try because the entire mommy
blogging genre is vapid and toxic family
and brain cell destroying it mostly
consists of women complaining about
their children their husbands and doing
so publicly of course but trying to
dress it up like it's an insight it's
really nothing it's just one long
complaint one complaint after another
but it's supposed to be supposed to be
insightful somehow Exhibit A we have
this article which has been getting
shared on social media a lot the past
few days from the mommy blog scary mommy
calm this was actually written a little
while ago but you know there's there's
no statute of limitations on
cancellations as we have learned so I'm
still gonna cancel this and all mommy
blogs because of it the title is my
daughter is hard to like and I'm sorry
alright here's here's a little bit of
the thing it says the day that I
realized my child is that child was a
turning point for me as a mother it's
the day I started to feel ashamed of my
daughter in the way she behaves the day
I started to wonder if there was
something wrong with her or with me as
the one who gave birth to her and is
responsible for making her into a decent
human being yes bingo you know I think
she see right at the top there she
stumbles on the truth there is something
wrong with her but then she proceeds to
talk to go on for 2,000 more words
talking about her daughter not herself
she says it happened on a day like any
other we were having a playdate at our
house with friends whom we know very
well and have invited over countless
times before my five year old and her
four year old friend were running laps
around the couch playing tag
my daughter was it and when she couldn't
catch up to her friend she collapsed on
the ground pouting close to tears and
shouted I can't catch you you have to
slow down you have to I won't play
anymore if you don't and I looked at her
with a sigh as I always do at times like
this and I looked at her friend who is
almost always smiling agreeable and
that's what I knew I knew that a
hypothesis that had been building in my
head and my heart for months and months
now was unequivocally true my
child is not easy to like well I think
part of the problem here is that your
child's acting like a brat in public and
acting out and your response is just to
sigh you're just staring there you're
staring at her as your as your child has
a temper tantrum just going huh
geez here she goes again what are you
gonna do well you could do something
you're the mother and it wasn't because
of that one event it was because that
wasn't an isolated event at all things
like that happen all the time all the
bloody time whether she is alone with
her siblings or their friends or at home
or in public my daughter is the bossy
one the demanding one the one making a
scene at the store is she cries on and
on and on because I won't let her buy a
gymnastics leotard she is quick to cry
yell throw the kind of tantrum that I
once thought only two-year-olds were
capable of she's disrespectful and rude
she's moody unable to share and overly
concerned about every damn toy insisted
upon doing things her way impossible if
things don't go her way manipulative
always thinking only of herself and
always prepared to tell you exactly what
she thinks and feels in that very moment
if she doesn't like what you are doing
she you will hear about it on and on I
mean just just a long oh my goodness
it's a long list this is a long
indictment that this woman is publishing
about her five-year-old and she says
that later on she says for those of you
who encounter my darling big eyed brat
you will be forgiven if you don't like
her I often don't like her myself I am
her mother and I love her because I have
enjoyed her at her best I recognized her
potential I know her strengths and then
it goes on and on as women tend to do
and finally at the end of it she pleads
that for the public to help her parent
by straightening her daughter out with
peer pressure
she actually tries to solicit peer
pressure against her daughter because
she's given up on actually parenting
okay
a few things here first of all you
shouldn't love your child for their
potential you're supposed to love them
period just to love them because you're
the parent loving your child for her
potential is a problem because what if
she never lives up to the potential your
idea of her potential are you gonna stop
loving her I guess so apparently so
second your child is a reflection of you
okay which which isn't to say that a
child who acts out you know or whatever
or misbehaves always has a bad parent
that would be ridiculous of course all
kids act out all five-year-olds are
varying degrees of difficult kids also
have their own minds and personalities
and you can only do so much to control
them and kids will go through especially
difficult phases at one point or another
I think it's probably different for all
kids you hear about the terrible twos
you know in my my wife and I talk all
the time about we never really
experienced that - for us is pretty easy
age three becomes the difficult age so
it's more you know three is more of that
it's the terrible three is more than the
terrible twos but it's different for
every kid in every family that said if
your child is an absolute terrorist then
yes you're doing something horribly
wrong
most likely in the child-raising
department to dislike them to dislike
your own child is not only pretty
horrible in its own right but it misses
the point if you're gonna dislike anyone
you should dislike yourself they're
taking cues from you okay this isn't
happening in a vacuum
kids can often be a mirror reflecting
ourselves back to us and that can often
be the most difficult thing about them
um in fact I find that the aspects of my
children's personalities that are the
hardest for me to deal with are the
aspects that are exactly like my own
personality stubbornness temper absent
mindedness you know all of that that's
me being disorganized you know another
thing that's that's how I am that's my
kids am I gonna resent them for what
failing to be a better person than me
failing to be more mature than I am
that's that's absurd but I really think
that's a lot of the anger that parents
experience that their kids is is this
now they don't think of it like this but
a lot of the time they're angry at their
kids for failing to be better than
themselves
they hold their kids to a higher
standard than they hold themselves and
on the outside for outsiders it's always
easy to identify so I don't know what
the first thing about this woman but I
I'm willing to bet if I if we you know
if you knew her and you saw her kid all
the ways her kids acting you would say
oh yeah well that's exactly how the mom
is it's no surprise at all bossy bratty
you know always have to have your way
materialistic I'm betting that the mom
is exactly like that yet here she is
proving that she's in fact a lot worse
than her kid because she resents her
child for doing all the same stuff she
does I mean if you do it how could you
possibly expect your kid not to do it
that's not fair to them that we have to
understand the limitations of a child
which is another challenging of a
challenge of parenting to understand the
kids limitations and to work within
those limitations and to not expect more
than what is possible if you're
expecting your child to be better than
you and to to to you know be more
virtuous than you and more mature and to
overcome personality defects that you
have not overcome well then you are
expecting too much of your child and you
have no right to do that
straighten yourself out first because
the main thing is with kids you know in
this is this is nothing radical or
revolutionary but they they ninety
percent of what they learned they
learned not based on what you say to
them but just based on copying what you
do so if you want them to act a certain
way then exhibit that behavior
show them what if you never show them so
get all these parents walking around and
all parents laps into it sometimes I
know I do
at times I but I'd always try to catch
myself it's but it's the dumbest thing
when parents are mad at their kids for
not acting in a way that they the
parents have never demonstrated okay you
want your kid to be a certain way show
them how don't just tell
don't just stand there I demand that you
be better than this be better I demand
it for some reason it doesn't resonate
with a five-year-old show them
demonstrate and they'll copy you if
you're not doing that there's no hope if
you're not even trying to demonstrate
good behavior to your child then your
child's gonna be a brat and you know
what it's not their fault it's your
fault you have no right to be angry at
them
you really don't 100% your fault
and then finally third you know even
aside from all this however your kid
acts brat or not you really don't need
to put this online these are things that
you save for your therapist or your
husband got help in or you know a friend
or whatever but you don't this doesn't
need to be online for everybody we don't
all need to hear it but this is what
parents do now where they just they vent
about their kids on a public forum
you're venting about your child to
millions of people and your child one
day is gonna grow up and read that
themselves and see what our utter ly
insufferable selfish whiny petty brat
you were which maybe will be helpful for
them to see that and then and then you
know they can start to recover and heal
themselves but but even so I would say
it's probably better just to keep all
that crap to yourself we did you know we
just we don't need to hear it and that's
my advice but anyway mommy bloggers are
cancelled anyway so you're not gonna be
you can't say anything anymore
online because you're cancelled and
that's it this video is sponsored by
blink sale the revolutionary invoicing
software for contractors and small
businesses spend less time billing and
more time making bank with blink sale
get a free trial at the link in the
video description